[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode a
Kos and by what's going on in the
background you see who that is
that's the protagonist Optimus Prime
brought to you by prime won Studios one
of the premiere studios and statue
collective and this is generation 1 but
hey before we get started so a lot of
you know I lost my daily departed sir
Benjamin Johnson not too long ago this
year and I want y'all to welcome cardi B
Johnson to the realm yes I say cardi B
my name is cardi Bacardi Johnson that's
right and y'all know cream Johnson going
up the steps so listen let's get this
video started all right as I hold her
and try to get this done she's been
really good right now alright so I grew
up watching the Transformers now
remember I told you in the last episode
with Megatron how when the Transformers
first came to the planet they were
fighting on like a waterfall overlooking
the cliff it was it was it was um it was
an epic battle between Optimus Prime and
Megatron and Optimus Prime had a photon
acts and this exclusive edition comes
with the same photon acts in that first
battle so this is the one I was able to
get exclusive it comes with three switch
out pieces on that is the right hand of
Optimus Prime
so he has his signature Canon as you can
see then he has the signature photon axe
and then later on in other episodes they
gave him a regular mechanical axe
because I guess they wanted to walk away
from the energy weapons that Megatron
and Optimus Prime was using you know so
remember this is generation 1 so I used
to run home and watch the Transformers
and it showed me a lot about camaraderie
but underlining I just didn't know was
really about politics to be honest with
you I didn't know that the Autobots was
refugees stranded on our planet all that
stuff went over my head all I know it
was they were cool and it was able to
transform from cars that I see in the
street to actual giant robots and how
cool is that for a kid to see giant
robots and then it was actually battling
now that's absolutely amazing so let me
give you a wild story
my cousin and I cut school right and hey
I'm not advocating anyone cutting school
do not cut school because let me tell
you what happened to me when I did so
right so transformers the movie came out
that's and I thought that it was just
gonna be a big episode right lo and
behold when we got to the movie theater
we snuck inside white store movie
theater we got in there and I don't
advocate you sneak inside the movie
theater either okay now we snuck inside
the movie theater and as we got inside
we started to watch the movie as you
know in the opening credits transformers
are dying this Senate chill up my spine
I'll never see no transformer die I've
never seen them turn from from colorful
to gray and colorless I didn't see them
shooting them and actually doing harm
usually they just shoot in they fall
away and it's like I'll be back another
day no in this movie my transformers my
beloved beloved Autobots and some
Decepticons were dying this was real
all-out war so watching the movie I'm
like what is going on I was bewildered
as a child just that this can't be
happening and then when Optimus Prime
died and they passed a matrix of
leadership from his chest to Omega
Supreme
Tiz filled my eyes I cried as a child it
still bothers me to this day that was
one of my greatest cartoon movies
because it changed the way I view
cartoons it turned it into they're no
longer immortal they can actually get
harm like us so it kind of changed me
when I watch cartoons because I didn't
go on with that
Kilis of video watching cartoons I
actually sort of cartoons in a different
light like I gotta appreciate them
because I don't know if they're gonna
remove them you know off but you know in
in cartoon world they brought back
Optimus Prime and later episodes and he
wanted his matrix of leadership back
from Rodimus Prime it was
a moment in time for me that music you
got the touch come on man I'm singing
hard rock tunes
uh herb in you from the Bronx is singing
hard rock tunes that bridge the gap to
me musically you know so it holds a big
place in my heart it's actually one of
the greatest movies that you can watch
and if you got children you can watch it
with them just let them know you know
hey some of the stuff but uh you know
cartoons nowadays is completely
different they actually show stuff like
that opposed to when we were being
exposed to it at a young age so let me
get into the statute so I had Megatron
and I had to get out to mr. prime so I
got optimus prime prime ones studios
exclusive edition with the three switch
out hands yes I did and if you look at
the detail on Optimus Prime you can tell
that it's so meticulously done the his
chest plate is an actual car window
glass right so it's actually glass not
car window glass but glass and like you
can see Co you know when he transforms
it's just as right there so that's
amazing the wheels on his leg is real
rubber that's amazing
his legs look like metal now mind you
this is not real metal this is a poly
stone and resin but it's done such a way
and the paint job is so good that you
can't tell the difference at all
you see the colors is spot-on the paint
job you have a little battle damage so
it looks like you know Optimus Prime was
in a and a little scuffle you can see it
in a paint job and that looks nice
some people don't like their stuff with
Battle Damage some some people that's a
turn-off for me is actually Plus
especially with this character because
Optimus Prime my Optimus Prime is a
leader that is rough-and-tumble and
doesn't send out his
soldiers to fight he can fight as well
he's actually the first one in line to
fight and then he lets his soldiers go
in and that's what a leader is he
doesn't just sit back and watch
he actually participates so this statute
I can't say it enough they're both equal
in height Megatron and Optimus Prime
they both equal in stature they both
look just like the cartoons and this was
one of the pillars in my my history of
my cartoon age you know he-man
Thundercats transformers and I'm trying
to get my hands on that Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles that I got a story to tell
for those Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
I'm still actively hunting down those as
we speak but I had to get this to you
and I hope y'all do stick around like
follow and subscribe hey and don't
forget hit that joining button down at
the bottom so you can see what the loads
are doing we wrapping things up around
now we're getting ready for packs and we
look to give you a whole lot of you know
behind-the-scenes stuff we got some
stuff that we're gonna actually release
to those people that join the channel I
would like for you to go to Lords of
gaming net where we have we have so much
news so much coverage going down from
all our super writers and I'm not just
saying that because I'm a part of it I'm
saying it because it's true I tell you
guys to go purchase the search from
teespring I actively wear these shirts
in my day to day life alright so go to
the website go look at hardcore reviews
with Lord addict the last word with
loyal Cognito Andy Montes and you can
also go get combat talk with the king
and that's that's that's me I'm about to
do the fight right now so um after this
video and also you can get other
episodes of Kos so if you didn't see
that Megatron episode please tune in and
check that out
hey stick around
if you're new to the channel stick
around and you can see this video this
is the statue in all its glory with
video and pictures and listen it to some
nice music without this guy talking here
see you next week and remember stay
collecting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]